hi i'm derek sarno i'm a vegan chef i
specialize in bringing mushrooms and veg
to the center plate by unleashing the
mighty flavors of plants
i co-founded a plant-based food company
called wicked kitchen and i lead
plant-based innovation at one of the
world's largest grocery retailers
in case you're wondering what
plant-based and vegan means it's super
simple vegan and plant-based foods are
entirely free from animals and from
their byproducts
think no animals harmed nor killed no
meat no fish
no dairy milk or eggs are used at all
just amazing plants vegetarianism also
doesn't contain animals or fish but
allows dairy and eggs the byproducts
taken from animals
here are a couple vegan things that i've
made recently
a steak no way
actually there are no t-bones about this
it's made of lion's mane mushrooms the
barbecue butter sauce cast iron seared
one of the most nutritious mushrooms on
earth and known to be brain boosting
pressed greek inspired souvlaki steak
sandwiches with all the fixins this one
is made with super sexy delicious brown
oyster mushrooms
grilled pepper steak kebabs great on the
barbecue packed with punchy flavors and
made with the super versatile and
delicious king oyster mushrooms yes
all of these are plant-based and all of
these are done with a variety of
mushrooms
why is this so important
meat-eating is linked to climate change
eating animals and animal agriculture is
the leading cause of rainforest
deforestation
meat production is the significant
source of greenhouse gas emissions and
there is a reason moms and doctors tell
us to eat more veg
that's partly why i'm a vegan chef
my other reason has to do with grief and
dealing with the unexpected death of
losing my partner
the suffering and grief i felt was
suffocating
i had two choices to go down a road of
self-destruction or accept what had
happened and find a way through it
the loss of amanda made me realize my
whole life to that point was based on
ego and attachment
being the best cooking anything and
everything without a second thought as
to the consequences of my actions
as long as the food tasted great and i
was paid well for it i didn't care where
it came from or if it was animals or the
implications and consequences that had
long story short i ended up laying my
old self to rest
selling off the food business and living
in a buddhist monastery for three years
where i learned to sit and studied
compassion and how my mind worked
what i discovered was a connection to
food and heart that i had ignored
animals suffered just as we do
from then on it became my mission to
find alternative ways to prepare amazing
food that not only benefited people but
avoided animal suffering as well
that time reflecting and learning helped
me reorientate my own moral compass and
opened up a whole new world of creative
cooking
it also helped me become much less of a
jerk
there are so many reasons to eat
plant-based and any reason that
resonates with you is the best reason
i understand it's not always easy
but eating even one plant-based meal a
day makes a huge difference
i used to be a long-time meat-eater as a
regular chef i used to cook lots of meat
and never made that connection that they
are living beings just like us with
feelings emotions and families
i'm now on a mission to unleash the
mighty power of plants to create foods
that we crave
full of flavors and textures that are
more nutritious and better for us and
the planet
i believe in compassionate action
and the way i express that is through
cooking and developing amazing recipes
that inspire and teach people how to
make and eat delicious foods without
animals
vegan food for meat eaters and vegans
alike because like most people i want to
save the animals and the planet but
there's no way that's going to happen if
i have to compromise on taste
thank you